[Music]
let's go to jake in sacramento
california what's up brother jake
hey thank you for taking my call dr john
how are you i'm good man how about you
doing all right doing all right um
well i i have an issue so my wife um is
a survivor of domestic violence
from a prior relationship of course
and she has
a lot of things that cause like
triggering events for her
so
i just wanted to know how i can best be
an advocate for her during that time
what i mean what i can do you know try
to help her get past that i know it's
gonna take a lot of time for her to heal
and
she may always have that kind of issue
but yeah what can i do to help her man
she's lucky to have you
it's awesome thank you
how long you've been married
oh boy um
going on five years okay so tell me
about
um triggers and episodes and what
happens
yeah so um if we go to like a certain
part of town
where some of these
things took place she'll kind of like
panic and get real quiet and
if she sees someone that looks like him
it's the same thing
she just kind of goes into this panic
and kind of
closes into herself if that makes sense
won't say anything just kind of freezes
if she feels like she's stuck like let's
say we're in the bathroom getting ready
together in the morning
i noticed this when we first got married
she would kind of do the same thing so
now i intentionally
get ready on the side where i'm kind of
stuck in the room and she has the
right next to the door you know sure
um
so just kind of those
things what about a certain
you can't go to certain restaurants
yeah certain restaurants we can't go to
like the ski park
up and north of us and you know just
stuff like that
um man
okay
um tell me about as much as you feel
comfortable tell me about sexual
intimacy you're all good thanks thank
you oh that's fantastic
sorry oh we partying brother no don't be
don't apologize that's what we waited
until we were married okay you know and
no it's been amazing cool okay
um
all right so
i'm going to say some things that are
going to people are going to have
comments on and that's fine
um
but
i'm just
man this one's close to home for me and
so i'm gonna be pretty direct okay
okay
number one your wife's lucky to have you
um most
partners can be not most many partners
can be insensitive to this um they don't
care or get over it or deal with it
whatever
and it sounds like you are
interested in your wife feeling safe and
your wife being well when i think that
she is lucky to have you good for you
i'm glad that that's your impulse and
that's your heart that's so good
thank you um
so
here
the basics of trauma is this her body
remembers these stories remembers the
location of these stories members the
guy who
um hurt her in the past where she was
hurt what was happening when she was
hurt the environment
and her body is now like if you think
about like terminator 2 one of those
scanning things with like the red
you know
night goggle vision right those red red
lights she's just scanning the
environment 24 7 365 for the next time
she's gonna get hurt
and her body's identified locations
people you know um uh
meal like whatever like all this
environmental stuff all the ecosystem
stuff and
when it when she finds herself in these
places
and she can't run she can't fight it
she's learned you just go numb right
we're gonna freeze we're gonna shut this
sucker down
and
here's the hard truth
you can like you were doing be really
careful about environmental triggers you
know this part of town's no bueno i'm
not going to this part of town these
restaurants aren't good this um
we're not going to the hockey game cool
we're not going to hockey game
you need to stand on this side of the
bathroom cool i'll stand on that side of
the bathroom those kind of things you've
been really accommodating for
those are avoidant those aren't healing
right okay
ultimately
your wife is going to have to decide
that she is not going to live under an
identity of ex-survivor
that she is going to
say i survived x
i lived through it
now i'm going to be about the healing
journey that comes next
and
lucky for her there are some incredible
trauma treatments
right and i do think given what you just
explained to me i do think she needs to
get with a trauma counselor
um and some of these things might take
years some of these things given her
partnership with you given that she's
got a safe home
man some of these things maybe 12 or 14
sessions
and that's it
and here's what trauma counseling does
it teaches you
ways to begin to take control back of
your own body
i'm going to control my breathing i'm
going to do these two or three things
when my heart rate takes off on me
i'm gonna learn these um
body safety things and then
with the help of a therapist
after three four five six sessions
we are then gonna go back through the
trauma narrative and here's why i'm
gonna do that
i'm gonna take these new tools i have
about how to let my body know that we're
safe now we weren't but we are now
and we're gonna stop our bodies from
telling this old story in the present
through you know diarrhea through
vomiting through shutting down through
getting silent through getting scared
through clenching all those things that
trauma survivors experience
and we're going to go back through the
trauma narrative we're going to tell
that story
until this exposure right until
my body stops taking off on me or when
it does i know how to take care of it
we're going to things like exposure
therapy we're going to go to the other
part of town
and we're going to have these new tools
and we're going to breathe through
when we were in this part of town 10
years ago eight years ago we weren't
safe now we're safe
now we're okay
and this is a process but it starts with
her deciding i want my body to heal and
here's where that's really hard number
one we live in a culture that gives
identity to the worst thing that ever
happened to you that becomes a who we
are
that we live out of
and the second thing that makes this
really hard
is that type of thinking in our minds
and in our bodies keeps us safe it kept
us alive and what we have to know is the
things that work to keep us alive then
are slowly killing us now
and that's a hard shift
it will feel for a season like she's
losing control like she is intentionally
putting herself in harm's way
and that's where those new things we
learn about how to breathe through
things how to roll with things
how to instead of clamming up to reach
over and grab your hand how to lean into
that discomfort when we're surrounded by
people that are keeping us safe that or
that or have our safety in mind and then
slowly the body goes oh yeah we're good
we're good now and then two years three
years down the road you'll be in another
part of town and she'll have forgotten
about it and she'll be like oh oh look
at this we're in this part right
that's gonna take some work but she's
gonna have to decide that
right here's where this is hard here's
go ahead
oh sorry she has gone to several
counselors
a lot of them
say that they can't do anything a lot of
them have broken down crying in the
middle of their sessions which is
interesting
hey that's sort of that sort of empathy
i'm okay with
but you can't talk your way out of
something that somebody beat into you
right
there's no amount of oh okay
this is something that you have to
practice
and
whether it's tfcbt or whether it's emdr
whether it's some of these things tftbt
is usually with kids but there's some
great great counselors who can help so i
would
specifically ask for somebody who is
skilled in
seeking safety skilled in
trauma counseling
that what's frustrating for me is when
you get with a good trauma counselor the
healing can be not always can be
relatively fast
a couple of months
six or seven months three or four months
maybe a year and so if there's systemic
abuse that went over years and years and
years from your parents and sexual abuse
some of that stuff will last for years
and years
some stuff can be healed quicker if the
therapist knows what they're doing and
if you have a client who's willing to
jump in with both feet
but
just traditional let's just sit down and
talk about this
man
that's that is there's some literature
that suggests that's re-traumatizing
because your body's re-experiencing this
but you haven't given your body any new
tools on how to deal with it
that's why i'm so such an advocate of
writing stuff down that's why i'm such
an advocate of breath work that's why
i'm such an advocate of moving your body
letting these stress chemicals when they
set off letting them have a place to
cycle through and not just get stuck in
your body and loop and loop and loop and
loop i'm a huge fan of emdr i'm a huge
fan of body movement therapy right
um there's there's a lot of modalities
if you get a trained person in your
corner and i hate hate hate that you
guys got somebody that was
didn't know what they were doing or they
didn't stop and say hey i need to pass
you on i've got a reference of three
people that can help specifically with
this sort of
um physical abuse trauma i hate that for
y'all please don't give up on
therapy just because y'all got a couple
of bad apples okay
yeah no no she's cool she's been
actively looking cool so here's what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna send you a copy of my
new book on your past change your future
case i want you to hang on the line i'm
gonna send it to you for free it's my
gift
and you all read that together and okay
there are sections in the book on trauma
the whole book is about about empowering
people to say you know what i am worth
what comes next
and while we do walk through it it's not
a substitute for trauma therapy but i do
believe it will really really help
somebody in their journey as they're
walking out of something like this okay
i appreciate it also it'll help you
because i know this is hard for you and
people don't talk to those
people don't talk enough about loved
ones who love people who have
experienced trauma
and some of this rubs off on you and
some of this you begin to look in the
mirror and be like am i just worthless
what about me and then you feel bad for
thinking what about me am i right
yeah yeah spot on okay so um i want you
to read this book too because you all
read it together and it would be really
cool if you all read this together and
you read a chapter she read a chapter
and then y'all had some time to talk
about it or you had a journal that you
kept between the two of you and you
wrote about what you thought in chapter
one and then handed it to her
and y'all go back and forth and you'll
keep a dialogue going and for someone
who's experienced trauma
the act of saying it out loud can be
brutal so having a place to write it
down might be a great
thing for you two to do together and
then my goal is if i've done my job at
the end of this book you're both
on the same team ready to take on the
world and when you get there man healing
becomes a way of life it's not this big
scary um overwhelming thing okay
okay so hear me say this there's there's
a bright light at the end of the tunnel
and for your wife that light is a
it's the size of a ballpoint pen
and hold her hand through this and i
think y'all are gonna be in
heading in a good direction
therapist listening to the show
if somebody comes into your office
do not ask
do not ask for the trauma story in the
first session or the second or the third
or the fourth until you've equipped them
with some skills some things they can
practice
because when they start down that road
and their body takes off on them it's
traumatizing to just sit in your office
and have a discussion about what
happened to you in the past
without giving them any tools
it's unethical don't do that it hurts
people and i also know because i've been
there
a client walks in and says hey you're
not going to believe what happened and
you literally want to know i'm curious
stop them and say
there will be time in this session to
hear about the assault the rape the time
that somebody beat you within the inch
of your life someone that you loved
there will be time to tell that story
that's not today
we're gonna do some work so that when we
go down that road
when we're ready for that when you're
ready for that
then we'll be able to go through that
story together and i'll be right here
with you
and you'll have some tools on how to
deal with it
please be a a therapist of integrity and
if you're not equipped to deal with
trauma you better get equipped quick
because that's the 22nd century the 21st
century and all the people coming over
from the 20th century that's our job now
get equipped get equipped take every ceu
you can read every book you can get all
the trainings you can learn how to be a
trauma-informed therapist start today